As the star of one of the most long-lived
superhero film franchises, Hugh Jackman has
been contractually obligated to keep his body
in a near-constant state of shreddedness since
1999.
That's just how it goes when you're famous
for playing a character whose costume often
consists of one pair of adamantium claws and
a veiny pair of pecs.
But how did Jackman transform from a 6-foot-2,
180-pound beanpole into the musclebound Wolverine?
Here's everything that goes into making, and
maintaining, his incredible physique.
He never skips the gym
If you've been watching Jackman play Wolverine
since the very beginning, you might have noticed
that he hasn't just kept himself in terrific
shape — he's clearly set out to make each
of his appearances even more physically intimidating
than the last.
When Jackman first showed up in 2000's X-Men,
he looked good... but in an achievable way,
like your friend from work who goes to the
gym in the morning and only drinks light beer.
Celebrity trainer David Kingsbury revealed
Jackman's formula for success, and it involves
going to the gym six days a week, twice a
day.
The actor follows a four-week workout cycle
when he's planning to slip back into his adamantium-laced
bones.
The first three weeks are all about lifting
heavy, and pushing huge amount of weight for
only a few repetitions.
The fourth week, Jackman de-loads and lifts
smaller amounts but at a higher volume, which
stimulates muscle growth so that he'll be
as big as possible on-screen.
The whole thing is pretty much murder on his
wardrobe.
"There boxes in my storage: fat suits, skinny
suits, and normal suits.
And  um, right now, in this shape,
I don't have any suits."
Jackman told the LA Times that there's one
thing that he favors above all when it comes
to transforming his body for a new X-Men movie:
the deadlift.
And that's not just a clever pun.
He eats all the food
When it comes to building a screen-ready physique,
your workouts are less than half the battle.
"You've got to train and you've got to train
hard.
If you don't eat right, none of it matters."
To get Wolverine-style muscles, Jackman has
to seriously shovel it in.
Jackman told Men's Fitness,
"I eat more, but I eat a lot stricter.
Seventy percent of your physique is your diet,
and diet is the biggest change that happens.
There were times when I would literally eat
with the mindset of working out.
'One more mouthful, one more, come on, come
on, you've got to finish this meal.'"
The actor's X-Men diet of 6,000 calories per
day was recommended by a guy who knows a thing
or two about getting buff for a role.
"I literally rang Dwayne Johnson, 'The Rock.'"
"OK."
"I've seen you in some movies.
What's going on?
What do I do?"
And before you go thinking that this doesn't
sound so terrible, keep in mind that Jackman's
superhero diet is high in calories but low
in carbs, which means that he has to get those
6,000 calories primarily in the form of grilled
chicken breast, spinach, and the occasional
scoop of brown rice.
...Though Jackman was seen celebrating with
some very un-diet-like foods after Logan finished
filming.
He uses what nature gave him
Before you spend the rest of your life weeping
into a bowl of buttered popcorn over the unattainable
awesomeness of Hugh Jackman's abs, know that
getting a body like his isn't just a question
of chicken breasts, bicep curls, and impeccable
genes.
Jackman's trainer explained that the actor's
diet and training regimen included the use
of creatine, a supplement that stimulates
muscle growth beyond what the body can accomplish
on its own.
He explained,
"We used a pre-workout product called Animal
Pump.
While bulking, we used creatine in the product,
and when cutting, we reduced, and then removed
the creatine."
It's not exactly the Weapon X program — even
the strictest anti-doping regulators are cool
with the use of creatine, and it's been a
regular item on the menu for bodybuilders
and athletes since the 1990s.
But it is one of the reasons why you don't
look like Wolverine despite your best efforts.
Broadway bod
Jackman is a stage actor first and foremost,
with a background on Broadway.
He'd be the first to tell you that Wolverine,
for all his exceptional talents, would not
be much of a dancer.
So, the actor doesn't hang onto his superheroic
physique when he's doing shows in between
superhero flicks.
He told the LA Times,
"[When] I dance I drop muscle very quickly.
The body is very smart and efficient, and
a traditional dancer's body is not going to
be bulked up on top because they're muscles
that you don't really need."
While doing stage work may cost Jackman his
biceps, it also has the benefit of keeping
Jackman in terrific shape.
When the cameras stop rolling, the actor still
stays busy and active, and doesn't let himself
go.
So when it comes time to bulk up beserker-style,
he's starting from a very good place.
He stays accountable
Getting in superhero shape isn't just diet
and exercise — it's also a question of mindset
and motivation.
So, where does Jackman get the mental fortitude
to endure the months of torture that precede
a new X-Men flick?
He gets it from you, of course.
Jackman always makes sure his followers know
when he's back in the gym, and that's not
just because he enjoys watching his Instagram
likes roll in.
When you've taught your fans to expect photos
and videos of you doing clap pushups or deadlifting
the weight of a fat Shetland pony, you've
gotta bring it at the gym or risk disappointing
them.
So when you follow Jackman on Instagram and
dutifully press that little heart icon for
his clips from the gym, you're doing your
part to make sure he shows up in Logan looking
like a muscular nest of pythons with a human
head.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!